[Music]
81% of white evangelicals voted for
Donald Trump in the previous election
that's a record that's more white
evangelicals than voted for George W
Bush and George W Bush was a white
evangelical this makes no sense to
people especially when you consider that
Trump is not just the most irreligious
president in modern history that his
entire worldview makes a mockery of core
Christian values like humility and
empathy and care for the poor that this
individual who couldn't even name a
single verse in the Bible when asked to
do so and yet and yet received a record
number of votes by white evangelicals
scholars of religion normal rational
people have been trying to figure out
why why what happened and I think that
there's a couple of things to keep in
mind number one it's white evangelicals
81% of white evangelicals voted for
Trump but 67 percent of evangelicals of
color supported Hillary Clinton now
these are people who believe the exact
same thing whose only real difference is
that is the color of their skin so let's
not ignore the fact that there is a
racial element to this support Jim
Wallace the head of the sojourners a
liberal evangelical group said it best
when he said that these white
evangelicals quote acted more white than
they did evangelical and I think he's
right the second reason I think it has
to do with the the pernicious influence
of something called the prosperity
gospel which has gripped the
imaginations of white evangelicals this
is that version of Christianity preached
by these charlatans like Joel Olsteen
and TD jakes the essential gist of which
is that God wants you to drive a Bentley
that what Jesus really wants for you is
material prosperity and indeed that
how you know God has blessed you is by
your material prosperity many white
evangelicals looked at Donald Trump and
what they saw was a wealthy men and that
wealth as far as they were concerned was
just a sign of God's blessings and so
that freed Trump from having to do what
every other candidate certainly every
other Republican candidate for president
has had to do and that is actually prove
his spiritual bond of bona fides Trump
never had to do that all he had to do
was just keep talking about how rich he
was and for a large swath of white
evangelicals that was enough thirdly
Donald Trump did something that no other
president not even any Republican
president courting the event evangelical
vote ever did he expressly promised
secular power to these white evangelical
groups in his speeches to them and and
in the conference's that he had both
private and public he very clearly and
very explicitly said that if they voted
for him that he would give them quote
their power back even if he didn't agree
with their pet causes that he would just
allow them to have those causes and you
can see as president you know he's
talking now about removing for instance
than Johnson amendment
which is an amendment that prohibits
preachers and churches from actually
engaging directly in in politics in
preaching politics from the pulpit it's
why they get to keep their their tax
break no one has ever thought about
removing this requirement until Donald
Trump and now he is very seriously
moving towards allowing churches to take
part directly in political activism as
churches but none of this none of this
explains the most important phenomenon
about white evangelicals in America and
that is this in the span of a single
election cycle white evangelicals have
gone from being
the group in America that is most likely
to say that a politician's morality
matters to the group that is now least
likely to say that atheists in America
think that a politician's morality
matters more than white evangelicals in
America do white evangelicals who
continue to refer to themselves as value
voters this is a phenomenon that can't
be explained by just looking at the
prosperity gospel are looking at racial
matters what you're seeing is a gigantic
group of Americans who are fundamentally
overturning their core theological
beliefs that public morality matters and
the only explanation that I have for it
is that Donald Trump has turned a large
swath of white evangelical Christianity
into a cult into a religious cult a
dangerous religious cult all the signs
are there you know Donald Trump
functions as he himself admitted when he
said offhandedly that he could shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue and not lose
voters he has become a kind of a
prophetic divine character pat robertson
the head of the 700 club of very
influential white evangelical literally
said that god took him in a dream up to
heaven and he saw donald trump sitting
at the right hand of god you know who
actually sits at the right hand of god
according to evangelicals jesus christ
in other words pat robertson is saying
that donald trump is essentially jesus
christ fact that's not that weird his
own evangelical adviser pastor by the
name of Jeffers said not too long ago
that he would prefer Donald Trump as a
candidate over someone who quote
expresses the values of Jesus so what we
are seeing now
is that these white evangelicals not all
of them but a bit of fundamental core of
them have essentially latched on to
Donald Donald Trump as almost a salvific
character they don't just follow him
they don't just agree with him
they almost worship Him and my fear is
that as we know from our very recent
history cults when confronted with the
realities of the world can often end in
catastrophic ways we have a presidency
that is deteriorating a president that
is spiraling out of control we have open
conversations now about the 25th
amendment and impeachment we have
multiple investigations and the
possibility of indictments at the
highest level this is a presidency that
is in danger of completely
disintegrating that wouldn't be such a
big deal if it weren't also a religious
cult because when a religious cult
begins to deal with this kind of
situation when their cosmic ideas are
are suddenly budding up against the
reality of of a failed leadership they
tend to double down and that's why I
think that we're in a very dangerous
place as a country right now because the
only thing more dangerous than a cult
leader like Trump is a martyr to cult
leader
[Music]
you